[موسيقى]
تقول الطرفه جلس اينشتاين ذات مره بجانب
سياسي لبداديا في القطار فاراد ان يختبر
ذكائه التفت اليه وعرض عليه اللعبه
التاليه انا اسالك سؤالا اذا لم تعرف
الجواب تعطيني خمسه دولارات ثم تسالني انت
واذا عجزت انا عن الاجابه اعطيك 500 دولار
هي كل ما احمله الان وافق السياسي
اللبناني وبدا اينشتاين ما سبب جاذبيه
الارض سال
فكر المسؤول قليلا ثم اخرج من جيبه خمسه
دولارات مستسلما وجاء دوره بالسؤال فقال
ما هو الشيء الذي يصعد الى الجبل بثلاث
ارجل وينزل برجل واحده ساعه كامله
استغرقها اينشتاين بالتفكير وانتهت بدفعه
الخمسمائه دولار للسياسي وساله في نهايه
اللعبه وما هو ذلك الشيء الذي يصعد الجبل
بثلاث ارجل وينزل برجل واحده
فاخرج اللبناني من جيبه خمسه دولارات
واعطاها لاينشتاين الذي حرم اللعب على
نفسه
وخصوصا مع السياسيين
الى العناوين
خاطئوا السعيديه حزين بعد مقتل مغربيين
برصاص جزائري
جيش الاحتلال يعري 5 فلسطينيات بالكامل في
مدينه الخليل
العشائر العربيه تضرب قصد وانتفاضه
السويداء متواصله
القذافي حي يرزق بجسد جديد وعمليات تجميل
هل تفقد فرنسا نفط الجابون بعد يورانيوم
النيجر
بهارات بطعم واحد اسمه الهند الجديد قريبا
هل يقف ماكرون على ابواب المدارس لمنع
العباءه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ليس دور الاعلاميين العرب ان يكونوا
شيوخ صلح بين حكومتي المغرب والجزائر اما
صون الاخوه بين الشعبين يكاد يكون فرض عين
على كل من امتلك منبرا او رساله انما
المؤمنون اخوه
استعل الغضب في المغرب بعد مقتل مواطنين
بنيران خفر السواحل الجزائري بعدما ضلا
بالخطا طريقهما البحريه مع مغربيين اخرين
عند الحدود المائيه مع الجزائر اثناء
تنزههم بالدراجات البحريه السريعه
في رحله عبر متن دراجه مائيه مع شقيقه
الاكبر واثنين من اصدقائه عندما ظلوا
طريقهم في البحر قباله السواحل مدينه
السعيديه المغربيه حيث يوجد منتجع ساحلي
مغربي يقع على الحدود مع الجزائر وفي
مقابله مع موقع 360 قال محمد كيسي شقيق
الضحيه ان خفر السواحل الجزائريه اطلقوا
النار عليهم وسائل اعلام مغربيه ذكرت ان
رجلا ثالثا وهو فرنسي مغربي اعتقل ومثل
يوم الاربعاء امام النيابه العامه
الجزائريه بينما اشارت الرباط ان الحادثه
شان قضائي الروايه الجزائريه الرسميه تقول
ان انذارات صوتيه عده اطلقت باتجاه الشباب
لكنهم لم يمتثلوا وهم في منطقه نشطه
لمهربى المخدرات والجريمه المنظمه لكن
للنازل المغربي من الحادثه روايه اخرى
وبعد اطلاق تحذير صوتي وامرهم بالتوقف عده
مرات الذي قبل بالرفض بل وقيام اصحاب
الدراجات المائيه بمناورات خطيره وبالنظر
الى ان هذه المنطقه البحريه الحدوديه تعرف
نشاطا مكثفا لعصابات تهريب المخدرات
والجريمه المنظمه وامام تعنت اصحاب هذه
الدرجات المائيه قام افراد حرس السواحل
باطلاق عيارات ناريه تحضيريه وبعد عده
محاولات تم اللجوء الى اطلاق النار على
دراجه مائيه كلنا سهتين والقرطاس
يتكلم خمسه قرطاسات خويا وصاحبي
الفاجعه والحداد الا ان الشباب المغاربه
الذين استطلعت ارائهم وسائل الاعلام
المحليه لم يبتعدوا عن رابط الاخوه عربا
وامازيغ في الوطنين الشقيقين كشعبين
المزايده على الحكومه المغربيه التي وضعت
الحادثه عند مسارها الطبيعي في القضاء
بعيدا عن اي اتهام مسبق يبنى على التحليل
والتسييس هذا من القضايا
من اختصاص السلطه القضائيه هذا الكلام
يمنع الاصطياد في الماء العكر الذي صبغ
للمفارقه مياها شاطئ السعيديه بعد الحادثه
باللون البني وهي ظاهره لم يع تد عليها
رواد الشاطئ
شوفوا
[موسيقى]
بدل فتاه يعموريه خمس فتيات فلسطينيات اما
بدل المعتصم فان الخدمه غير متوفره حاليا
في اي دوله اسلاميه
مجندهان اسرائيليتان ضمن قوه عسكريه من
خمسين جنديا وخلال اقتحام ليلي في مدينه
الخليل في العاشر من الشهر الماضي
اجبرتا خمسه سيدات فلسطينيات على التعري
بالكامل داخل منزلهن بعد اقتحامه وقد
توعدت فصائل فلسطينيه الاحتلال
بتدفيعه الثمن بحسب التحقيق فان مجندتين
اسرائيليتين مسلحتين كانتا ضمن دوريه
عسكريه ومعهما كلب مهاجم اجبرت خمسه سيدات
فلسطينيات من عائله في مدينه الخليل على
السير عاريات وهددت
الكلب نحوهن اذا لم يطعن الاوامر هل حولت
اسرائيل مدينه جنين ومخيمها الى حقل تدريب
حي لجنودها على الجريمه المنظمه بحجه
ملاحقه المقاومين الذين تصفهم بالمخربين
طيب ماذا عن الاطفال والاحتلال يعتقل منهم
160 طفلا وطفلا في السجون وهل يليق باي
عصابه في العالم اي ينقض جنودها على طفل
دون سن التمييز لاختطافه ثم اعتقال شقيقته
التي دافعت عنه
[ضحك]
لو سمحت لو سمحت
انتفاضه العشائر العربيه السوريه في دير
الزور مزدوجه ضد قوات قصد ونظام الاسد
ومقاتل العشائري يكتسحون مناطق دير الزور
دون مقاومه صلبه من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قصد كان المتوقع ان ياخذ
تحرير دير الزور من يومين الى ثلاثه فجاءت
المفاجاه بتحرير عشرات القرى والبلدات
خلال خمس الى ست ساعات علما ان الرقم
القياسي اعاقه زج عصابات قنديل بالعناصر
العرب على جبهات القتال الامر الذي دفع
بثوار العشائر لتوجيه نداءات صوتيه قبل
اقتحام مقرات ميليشيا قصد وتامين انشقاق
العناصر الذين وصلوا للمئات ما بين افراد
وجمعت
الانشقاقنا عن قصد وانضمامنا الى مقاتلين
العشائر في الموازات تتواصل انتفاضه بني
معروف في محافظه السويداء على النظام الذي
يحاول امتصاصها عن طريق بعض المشايخ
الدروز لكن قسما كبيرا من المتظاهرين
والمتظاهرات هم من كبار السن ولا يريدون
لابنائهم واحفادهم ان يكرروا تجربه عيش
حياتهم في الخوف الدائم صاحب الحق سلطان
ونحن احفاد سلطان باشا الاطرش يقولون
[تصفيق]
بدي اولادي يطلعوا خايفين مثلنا والبناء
على الخوف خوفونا من الحي
ط بتسمع مع انتفاضه دروس السويداء تذكر
السوريون التصريحات القديمه الشهيره لوزير
خارجيه موسكو
عندما تحدث في بدايه الازمه عن منع حكم
المسلمين السنه بلدهم سوريا اذا عبر لافرو
في مقابله مع اذاعتك عن مخاوفه من سعي بعض
دول المنطقه للضغط من اجل اقامه حكم سني
في سوريا تصريحات اثارت لاستغراب
والادانته لدى اطراف كثيره شيخ سني في حمص
لم يقصر بكل الاحوال بمناسبه ازاحه الستار
عن تمثال جديد لبشار الاسد في المدينه
بكلفه عشرات ملايين الليرات فالقى خطبه
نسفت كل خطب الراحل مامون رحمه واعتبر ان
النقمه على الاسد سببها دفاعه عن الاسلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الرئيس بشار الاسد ولا ذنب لقائد هذا
الوطن الا استقامته واخلاصه ومحبته
ودفاعه عن العروبه والاسلام واذا كان
المسلمون مجمعين على انه تجب طاعه ولي
الامر ولو كان عبدا حبشيا اسود فكيف لمن
كان حرا وعادلا وصادقا ومخلصا لو ان
القذافي استخدمه بديلا عنه لامسك به
الثوار وبقي القذافي طليقا
شبيهه معمر يتجول في مدينه بني وليد
تزامنا مع ذكرا انقلاب سبتمبر بكل الاحوال
يؤكد الهتافون ان القذافي راجع بالمعلومات
وليس بالتحليل احدهم اخذه الحال فشبه
القذافي بالانبياء عليهم السلام وقال ان
معمر بعث لتجديد الدين لا حول
القلب الواسع
[موسيقى]
للبشريه لتجديد الدين لتجديد العقيده
للفهم العقائدي الناس تنحرف الناس التوب
في الدنيا الضلاله فبعث الله سبحانه
وتعالى لنا القائد معمر القذافي
[موسيقى]
لم اعد انتوي الترشح لقد فهمتكم قالها
رئيس السنغال مكيسال الذي سال عرقه على
وقع دومينو الانقلابات العسكريه في القاره
السمراء فهل هو ربيع افريقي ضد الاحتلال
الاوروبي الناعم اب خليف عسكري مرتبط
بالخارج جدد الرئيس السنغالي
يلتزم بعدم الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
اجراءها في 25 فبراير 2024 اذا كان رئيس
الكاميرون قد بلل ذقنه ليحلق لنفسه بيده
فان حكومتي رواندا والكاميرون قد حلقتا
لضباط كبار في الجيش قبل ان يحلقوا لحكام
البلدين
واعادتها هيكله المؤسسات العسكريه على
اساس الثقه بالولاءات المطلقه ورغم ان
بولمبيادو التسعين عاما يحكم الكاميرون
منذ واحد واربعين عاما الا ان حمى
الانقلابات في القاره السمراء يبدو انها
تدب الرعب بدول اخرى فيها بحسب تقارير
اعلاميه ربطت بين انقلاب بين النيجر
والجابون الاخيرين واجراء رئيس الكاميرون
تغييرات طالت قاده كبار في هيئه قياده
الجيش الوطني وهو الامر ذاته الذي حدث في
رواندا ايضا التي ستجري بحسب وسائل
تغييرات كبيره في الرتب العسكريه في جيشها
اجواء الرعب هذه التي تخيب على القصور
الرئاسيه الافريقيه سببها انقلاب النيجر
وعززها انقلاب جمهوريه الجابون التي
تحكمها عائله بونجو منذ 56 عاما على يد
مؤسس الوضعيه السياسيه للعائله
البار بونجو الذي صار لاحقا عمر بنجو
بعدما اسلم على يد معمر القذافي فاخذ عنه
ايضا تابيد الحكم وتوريث الرئاسه قبل
ايامنا تمت الاطاحه برئيس الجابون علي
بنجو خليفه والده عمر بن غو ثاني رئيس
للبلاد بعد استقلالها عن فرنسا فمن هي
عائله بانجو وكيف ادارت ثروه البلاد
الاب عمر بنجو انتخب رئيسا للغابون عام
1967 اسمه الحقيقي علبه
اسلم بعد مقابلته للرئيس القذافي في ليبيا
عام
1973 وعرف من حينها باسم الحاج عمر بانجو
حكم الغابون حتى عام 2009 وبعد وفاته تولي
ابنه علي بنجو الحكم الجابون ثالث اثرى
الدول الافريقيه بثرواتها الطبيعيه لكن
ثلث مواطنيها فقراء فقرا متقعا يعني اذا
كنت فقيرا في بلد غني بثرواته اعلم انك
لست وحيدا في هذا العالم هناك اخوه لك في
الجابون وذلك بفضل النفط والمغنيز والخشب
لكن ثلث سكان الغابون البالغي عددهم
2.3 مليون نسمه يعيش تحت خط الفقر مما لا
شك فيه ان لهذا الفقر غير المنطقي اسبابا
تتعلق بطمع عائله بونجو التي حولت الجابون
الى صاله بينجو قمار تديرها وتلعب فيها
وممنوع ان يربح فيها الا البوانج عائله
بونجو والشركات الفرنسيه
بشان مكاسب غير مشروعه وبحسب بحث اجراه
الموقع الاستقصائي الفرنسي ميديا بارت فان
شركه دلتا سانرجي القابضه المملوكه لعائله
بونغو تمتلك اسهما في جميع الشركات المهمه
تقريبا في الجابون بما في ذلك فروع
الشركات الفرنسيه من النفط والتعدين الى
البنوك وشركات التامين الفرنسيه هي اللغه
الرسميه في
رغم وجود اربعين لغه محليه فيها لكن فرنسا
ايضا اقتصاد قبل اللغه في البلاد فهل
سيقيدها الانقلاب لتخسر باريس نفط الجابون
بعد فقدانها يورانيوم النيجر فالمصائب لا
تاتي فرادى بعد يورو يمنيجر في فرنسا تفقد
معدنا افريقا جديدا معدن قادر على ان يعطل
صناعه السيارات
والبطاريات والبناء ورابع اكثر المعادن
استخداما في العالم
ومناجمها العملاقه التي تسيطر عليها
الشركات الفرنسيه
اصبحت الان خارج الخدمه
بهارات لن تبقى فقط في المطابخ وعلى
الموائد بل ستصبح دوله ملياريه انها الهند
التي تعتزم حكومه نارين درامودي تغيير
اسمها في جلسه
بعد اسبوع الى بهرات لكن المشكله هي ان
مودي لا يريدها بهارات مشكله يريدها بطعم
واحد وقد استبقت حكومتهم وافقه البرلمان
فطبعت الكلمه السنسكريتيه بهارات بدل
الهند على دعوات العشاء لقمه مجموعه
العشرين هذا الاسبوع
حزب مهاراتها جنتا يريد نشر ايديولوجيه
قوميه انه ينبغي تعريف الهند على انها
هندوسيه
بحث الجزء المتعلق بفتره حكم المسلمين
لذلك تم تنقيح الكتب المدرسيه لتقديم رؤيه
معينه للمجتمع الهندي اعلن عمده ولايه
نيويورك الامريكيه
عن السماح برفع الاذان عبر المكبرات
الخارجيه في مساجد المدينه
خلال شهر رمضان المبارك فقط فمن حق
المسلمين ان يمارسوا عباداتهم بحريه في
رمضان فقط ايها الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
[موسيقى]
مناسبه السماح بالاذان في نيويورك شهرا
واحدا في السنه على اهميتها لكنها تذكرنا
بعدم التسامح المزعوم من بعض دول الغرب
ويعزز كلام احمد موسى ورفاقه الذي كان
يؤخذ بالهزل بان مستوى الحريه
والديمقراطيه في مصر افضل من المعايير
الامريكيه لان المسيحيين يمارسون حريه
العباده كامله في مصر
يقرعون اجراس كنائسهم كل يوم بغض النظر عن
التعداد الديموغرافي لان التنوع لا يعرف
الاله الحاسبه فالمواطنه تشمل الجميع اما
في امريكا فما عدا الهنود الحمر حفظهم
الله الكل مهاجر ومواطن شفت ديمقراطيه
امريكا ازاي حابب اكلمكم عليها بعد شويه
امريكا اللي بتخترع لنا الديمقراطيه كل
شويه
ما عندهم حياه سيبك من الوهم وهم امريكا
ده انسوه اما تقعد بقى وتشوف الناس وتتكلم
انسوا الوهم انا النموذج الامريكي في
الديمقراطيه والحريه ما يعجبنيش
على مر الزمان ومهما اختلف المكان هيفضل
صوت الجرس رنان ويكون بنغماته مع صوت
الاذان احلى سيمفونيه تميز مهدي الاديان
ارض الكنانه بلدنا الحلوه فرنسا واحده من
اعلى الدول ارقاما في الجرائم الاسريه ضد
النساء فقد نقلت صحيفه
عن وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه تقريرا يفيد
عن مقتل امراه واحده كل ثلاثه ايام في
فرنسا بدل ان يهرع الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانيول ماكرون الى استحداث خطه طوارئ
وطنيه تحد من جرائم قتل الفرنسيين
لزوجاتهم فرا الى ابواب المدارس والجامعات
لمراقبه الطالبات المسلمات ومنعهن من
ارتداء ثياب طويله وفضفاضه
فلبس الضيق والقصير واجب وطني وقيمه كبرى
في قيم الجمهوريه الفرنسيه التي تعيش ازمه
في كل مكان بالعالم وزعيم المعارضه
اليساريه
يرصد هوسا ضد المسلمين في الخطاب الرسمي
لفرنسا من يصدق ان العباءه تشغل حيزا من
الخطاب السياسي الفرنسي في هذه المرحله
يجدد الرئيس الفرنسي دعمه لقرار وزير
التربيه منع ارتداء الازياء الطويله
والفضفاضه تحت مسمى العباءه داخل المدارس
اننا نعلم ان كثيرين سيحاولون تحدي النظام
الجمهوري وسنكون صارمين معهم للغايه هنالك
هاوس لديهم ضد المسلمين وكذلك في الخطاب
الرسمي لهذا البلد اذا كنت تعيش في الكويت
فكر 100 مره قبل ان تقدم على ضرب زوجتك او
اختك او ابنتك
اذا فعلت اذهب فورا الى اقرب مقبره وباشر
بتعلم سنن دفن الموتى لان عقوبه ضرب
النساء صارت في الكويت غسل الاموات
القانون الجديد لم يذكر شيئا عن الزوجه
التي تضرب زوجها او ابنها لكن العقوبه
التي تسببت بصدمه الكويتيين لكل من يعنف
زوجته او اي فرد على سبيل المثال هي
الاهتمام بشؤون الجنائز وبمعنى اصح غسل
الموتى هو يعاقب بعقوبه بديله هو غسيل
الجنائز لمده خمسه ايام في الاسبوع طبعا
اربع ساعات او او نظافه السجون او نظافه
الشوارع
[موسيقى]
ختاما في زمن الجمال الاصطناعي وتشابه
الوجوه وتشوهها احيانا يقال ان بعض البشر
يحتاجون فعلا الى اجراء عمليات تجميل
عاجله لكن من الداخل تضمن تكبير القلب
الضغين وصفط الحقد الدفين وتكسير خلايا
الشر في النفوس ونفخ جباه الكرامه في
الرؤوس وتكميم افواه الرذيله عن الكلام
وتزيين الشكل بالعقل والعقل زينه بين
الانام فلا الذكاء الاصطناعي مامون ولا
تجبيل الوجوه مضمون الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]